K. E. K. W. Moin Leute, da bin ich. Genauso pepo fett wie das letzte Mal. Ne das stimmt
nicht, ich hab weiter abgenommen. Leute es geht immer weiter abwärts. Was natürlich
sehr pogge ist, weil ich war vorher einfach zu dick. Aber jetzt, jetzt ist alles gut.
Ich kann nicht reden und tippen gleichzeitig, da erzähl ich einfach nur Blödsinn. Nicht
zusammenhängenden Kram. Denkt euch nichts dabei. Steinadler 5. 7 Monate Massive Subscription.
Dankeschön. Ich hab heute mal was lustiges von der Arbeit mitgebracht. Wir werden heute
natürlich anonymisiert. Ihr wisst ja, wir werden heute was bauen, was ich auf der Arbeit
brauche. Wir haben ja schon das ein oder andere Mal Sachen programmiert, die da ganz interessant
waren und die ich dann im Endeffekt für die Arbeit verwenden kann. Rechnest du das ab?
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, ob ich das abrechnen kann. Ich kanns mal probieren. Wahrscheinlich
könnte ichs auch abrechnen, aber ganz ehrlich, ich hab keinen Bock dazu zu sagen, guck mal
hier, hier hab ich live gestreamt. Ne. Letztendlich unterm Strich kommt aber was sinnvolles für
die Arbeit bei raus. Ich erzähl euch auch gleich was. Ist tatsächlich zum Teil etwas,
aber nur zum Teil. Es ist eine Mischung, es ist eine Mischung aus und so ungefähr. Weil
warum wir das machen, ist ziemlich monkaW bzw. eigentlich ist es lustig. Muss mal kurz
was gucken. Ich glaub Teams hat am Sounds wieder rumgestellt. Yep. Yep. Yep, Han hat
am Sounds rumgestellt. Während der Stream anläuft, ich mach mal die VM an und ich mach
mal Update und dann erzähl ich euch, ist die Wallbox schon montiert? Leute, ich sag's
euch. Ich wollt beim Elektriker einen Termin vereinbaren. Also ich hab mir vor, ich muss,
ok. Leute, ich mach mal ein paar Tabs zu, es ist einfach zu viel auf. Dann sag ich,
dann sag ich gleich was zu. Meine Güte, ist viel zu viel. Guckt euch das mal an. MonkaS.
Leiter gar nicht mehr auf. Wie sieht eigentlich, ok New World, New World, aha aha aha. Äh.
Was macht Battlefield? Na gut, die gehen jetzt wieder hoch, weil die haben hier Season 2
gelauncht. Season 2 hab ich tatsächlich noch nicht ausprobiert. Weiß jemand, wann Season
2 gelauncht ist? Hat das jemand von euch im Kopf? Gestern oder so? Wer ist denn vorgestern?
Wieso nicht lang her? Ja, aber um mal was zum Thema Wallbox zu sagen. Save. Was haben
wir denn hier? Ah, hier haben wir noch den Hetzer Kram auf. Das brauchen wir ja gar nicht
mehr. Oh, Moment Leute, ich mach mal nebenbei Update, dann erzähl ich euch was. Nichts
zum Updaten, das ist auch gut. Aber ich starte mal neu. Dann erzähl ich euch was. Also. Mach
mal Update. Cody? Was? Warum hab ich hier? Ok. Was auch immer. Installieren wir jetzt
einfach? Yes. Also, ja, zu diesem Thema. Ist die Wallbox schon montiert? Dazu kann ich
was erzählen. Also, für alle die sich mitgekriegt haben, jetzt nochmal ganz kurz in Kürze, ich
hab mir ein Elektroauto gekauft, nehm ich den hier. Und ich hab versucht, mir bei einem
Elektriker einen Termin zu machen. Der Konfigurator ist irgendwie kaputt. Von Fiat. Also das Ding
hat einen 42 Kilowattstunden-Agu. Und. Dementsprechend ist es natürlich ziemlich mühselig, das aus
dem. Ziemlich mühselig, das aus dem normalen Stecker zu laden. Ich habe mir bei Amazon
einen Stecker bestellt mit 10 Meter Kabel, dass ich das machen kann, bis ich ein Ladegerät
ins Zähne hab. Zumindest. Also. Ich hab mir dieses Ding gekauft als Elektroauto. Und jetzt
geht es darum, wie kann ich das möglichst schnell laden. Also hab ich mich mal umgeguckt,
was Ladeboxen angeht. Und ich hab mich entschieden für dieses Ding hier. Aus mehreren Gründen.
Also das hab ich auch schon bestellt bei Amazon, das liegt bei mir daheim. Die Seite ist wahnsinnig
geschwind, gerade aktuell. Das liegt bestimmt am Dark Reader. Dark Reader macht hier bestimmt
Probleme. Mach mal kurz. Wer von euch macht hier schon wieder Hacker, man? Gibt es 2Chat,
ihr seid das. Dass es so langsam ist hier. Twitch Chat Ddos. Nee, ist absolut null ausgelastet,
der Rechner. Guck mal, dieser Idle Prozess ist ganz schön aktiv. Niedu, Dankeschön für
den Sub. Ackermans. Genau, ich hab mich für dieses Ding hier entschieden. Und das liegt
daran, weil. Guck mal, ob die das hier in dieser Broschüre schreiben. Also. Es ist so,
wenn man ein 22 Kilowatt Ladegerät bei sich daheim installieren will, dann muss der Netzbetreiber
zustimmen und der Netzbetreiber will dann auch irgendeine Notabschaltung und sowas
da installiert haben. Da hab ich keinen Bock drauf gehabt, deswegen hab ich die 11 Kilowatt
Variante. So. Und warum hab ich mich dafür entschieden? Weil dieses Ding wirklich selten
ist es ja heutzutage. Offene Apis hat. Das Ding hat die Möglichkeit sich ins heimliche
WLAN zu hängen, per HTTP angesprochen zu werden und per MQTT angesprochen zu werden
und es gibt auch schon fertige. Es gibt auch schon fertige Integrations. Es gibt auch schon
komplett fix und fertige Integrations für Homosystem für das Ding. Mal gucken, ob die
was taucht, wenn ich. Oh ja, sehr große Schrift. Wenn nicht, mach ich. Hat Github irgendwas
geändert? Github sieht heute irgendwie ein bisschen anders aus. Ja, und wie gesagt, es
gibt fertige Integrations und dann kann man in seiner Heimautomatisierung das ganze Ladegerät
sinnvoll fernsteuern. Man hat dann zum Beispiel so Sachen wie automatischer Stop, mit wie
viel Ampere das Ding laden soll, man kann das ganze Limit, man kann sagen laden an,
aus und sonst was und in Kombination mit dann sein Auto quasi noch abfragen, wie voll
es ist, dann kann man richtig, richtig coole Sachen machen bzw. kann dann beispielsweise
auch sagen, ich lade plus bis 90 oder ich lade jetzt mal volle Pulle voll oder ich
lade vielleicht erst heute Nacht oder was weiß ich, ich lade jetzt gar nicht, ich fange
dann erst mal mit, was auch immer. Egal, man hat die Werte. Das ist einer der Hauptgründe,
warum ich gesagt habe, ich nehme die, weil die offene Apis hat. Du kannst HTTP und MQTT
machen. So, jetzt natürlich die Sache, ich habe das schon bei mir daheim liegen und jetzt
wollte ich beim Elektriker einen Termin machen und dann erzähle ich euch, was wir heute mit
Prometheus machen, was auf der Arbeit war. Also ich wollte einen Termin beim Elektriker
machen und ich habe ungelungen oder bei sechs, sieben verschiedenen Elektriker angerufen
und habe die gefragt, ich habe ein Ladegerät bei mir daheim und ich will das angeschlossen
haben. Ich habe mit dem Netzbetreiber schon alles geklärt und wisst ihr, was die allesamt
gemacht haben? Die haben allesamt das hier gemacht, als ich die angerufen habe. Alle,
die haben alle gesagt, es dauert Wochen bis Monate. Die haben wirklich, die haben sich
wirklich, die haben nicht das gemacht, die haben nicht das gemacht, die haben allen Ernstes
schon das gemacht. So, also die haben sich, die haben sich weggekackt und haben gesagt,
es dauert ein paar Monate bis ich dran komme. Also habe ich mal weiter, also ich habe, wie
gesagt, ich habe sechs, sieben Elektriker angerufen und der eine war geil, der eine war geil,
ähm, da habe ich angerufen und da war irgendwie, war irgendwie, klang irgendwie russisch oder
so, habe ich gedacht, hä, wo bin ich denn hier gelandet? Wo, wo, wo bin ich, wo bin
ich denn hier gelandet? Wie, wie, wie komme ich auf einmal bei den Gekommodats raus? Und
habe ich gedacht, ja, bin ich hier richtig bei, äh, ja, Elektriker Name, blablabla und
dann meint der, ja, sie richtig, aber ich probleme mit Deutsch. Da habe ich gemeint,
ach, das ist kein Problem, ich kann später auch anrufen, wenn irgendwie jemand da ist,
wo das, wo das besser funktioniert, müsste ich jetzt nicht anstrengen. Ähm, aber nein,
nein, nicht später anrufen, kann das auch machen. Äh, okay, ähm, dann, dann erzähle
ich ihnen jetzt mal, was ich will, habe ich gesagt, ich habe eine Ladestation gekauft,
will das bei mir, will das bei mir im Hof angeschlossen haben und dann das erste, bevor
der irgendwie gefragt hat, was ist das für eine Ladestation oder wo sind sie oder, oder
irgendwas, hat er zu mir gesagt, das, das, ne, was hat er gesagt, das wird kosten, hat
er gesagt, das wird kosten und da habe ich mir schon gedacht, hm, das klingt, klingt
jetzt erstmal nicht so vertrauenserweckend und dann meinte er weiter, das wird kosten,
900 Euro und da habe ich mir gedacht, hm, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen teuer, wenn
ich mir überlege, dass es einfach nur angeschlossen werden muss und die Station selber billiger
war, also nein, ich, ich schaue, ich schaue mich nochmal um, das wird kosten, naja, zudem
bin ich nicht und dann habe ich tatsächlich noch einen gefunden, der gesagt hat, nächste
Woche Mittwoch kann er sich das mal angucken, hast du schon eine Leitung zur Garage, ne,
die kommt bei mir nicht in die Garage, die kommt bei mir im Hof, dort wo nicht so viel
Sonneneinstrahlung ist und ein bisschen unterm Dach, im Hof, man kann direkt vom Keller,
man muss ein bisschen Verlängerungskabel machen, so, so, so eine Zwischenbox wahrscheinlich
an die Wand machen, aber das ist ja für einen Elektriker nichts, nichts wildes und dann
kann man vom Keller direkt durch, durch ein Fenster bzw. durch, durch ein Holzding im
Fenster in, in Hof und direkt an die Wand machen, ja, ich denke mal, wenn der so eine
Zwischenbox setzt und so, sagen wir mal, der ist eine Stunde beschäftigt, wenn das am
Ende 200 Euro kostet, meinetwegen, aber 900 Euro, also, das wird kosten, 900, 900 Euro,
also, ne, ne, wirklich nicht, zumindest, entweder monatelang warten oder 900 Euro, ich hab da
noch einen gefunden, ich hab da noch einen gefunden, der gesagt hat, er kann sich das
nächste Woche Mittwoch oder irgendwie dann die Tage mal angucken, wenigstens, aber ich
sag, nice, sehr gut, jetzt machen wir, auf gehts, Musik ist mir zu anstrengend, ich brauch
was entspannenderes, Leute, was, was hab ich da, oft hat der Chat irgendwann mal gepostet,
nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
wo ist, wo ist meine Relaxing, nein, auch nicht Kirby Go Mirrors, wo ist meine Relaxing Mario
Musik, wo ist es, Relaxing Mario, hier, das, die will ich haben, ah, yes, exellent, Entspannungsmusik
vom Anfang zu basteln, ah, ok, also, dann erzähl ich euch mal was, und zwar, also, was
wir heute machen ist folgendes, mal gucken, ob ich 5 hätte, das ist falsch, das wollte
ich gar nicht, wo bin ich, ah, wo bin ich, ich hab zu viele Tabs, Leute, Monka, hier,
das ist die Lautstärke, ah, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du,
du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du,
Fertig sind mein toolbox updates checken kurz und dann mache ich alles ab den guck mal da
Check vor updates also ich erzähle euch jetzt mal kurz was wir heute machen
Während der hier alles updatet also es gab was zu kecken bei mir auf der arbeit
Also richtig und zwar also ihr seht es ja schon im titel titel heute des streams ist ja mail
Monitoring mit prometo ist für die arbeit
Programme also was wir machen ist wir richten nicht wirklich ein komplettes mail monitoring ein wir programmieren einen check für mail
Monitoring und zwar wir programmieren einen check ob wir
Gepleckliste sind bei gmx und bei web.de
Und wer sich jetzt fragt warum
Ich werde jetzt mal ich werde das jetzt mal versuchen kurz zu erklären und zwar
Das sieht bei uns ich muss das versuchen ein bisschen abstrakt zu erklären also das sieht bei uns auf der arbeit folgendermaßen aus also
Wir haben jede menge außendienstmitarbeiter
Fast aber die details natürlich nicht also wir haben jede menge außendienstmitarbeiter
und die haben zum größten teil die haben natürlich email accounts bei bei der bank wo ich arbeite und
Die haben halt private private email accounts also die schicken auch mal
Kollegen was an ihre private adresse oder sich selbst an die private adresse oder schicken sie irgendwelche verträge an die private adresse ob es
Es dürfen oder nicht sei mal da ist einmal dahingestellt sie machen es aber so
Und jetzt ist folgendes folgendes passiert
Und genau also und jetzt ist folgendes passiert
irgendeiner oder wahrscheinlich mehrere oder was auch immer von unseren außendienstleuten haben gespammt
Ist meine vermutung wir wissen es nicht genau zumindest sind wir bei united internet auf der blacklist gelandet mit emails und
Das hat dazu geführt
Die machen das trickreich die sagen dir das nicht direkt wenn du dort versuchst per smtp deine email abzugeben da kriegst du dann
irgendeine meldung
Ich habe die meldung vergessen es könnte sogar irgendwas mit rate limit sein oder so also kriegst irgendeine meldung wo du nicht genau drauf schließen kannst
Dass sie dich geblacklistet haben oder rate limiten so um die sache noch ein bisschen komplizierter zu machen wir machen unsere externe mail
Kommunikation nicht direkt selbst wir haben einen anbieter der für uns
Eingehen spam filter macht und ausgehend quasi mit seinen mail server
mit dem guten namen da steht dass man nicht geblacklistet wird weil
Sowas willst du in der regel nicht selbst betreiben wenn du das über den anbieter machst der größer ist fest bekannt ist mails verschickt
Da wirst du eigentlich seltener geblacklistet so was jetzt passiert ist
Irgendjemand bei uns hat gespammt
Die spam mail sind über unseren spam filter anbieter rausgegangen der filter natürlich nur eingehenden spam
Die haben das verschickt an gmx und web.de und was noch was gehört dann freenet und so
Was gehört noch ein was gehört alles zu united internet
Was sind da alles dabei?
Gmx web.de mail.com strato
Also da der ganze das ganze geht durchs
Und
Die emails sind halt nie bei den empfängern angekommen
Und unser spam anbieter der dazwischen ist hat allerdings auch die fehler meldung von gmx und von united internet
Nie an uns weitergeleitet das heißt united internet hat uns gesperrt in kombination mit
unserem absender also mit unserer domain und von den email servern
und dann war halt
Nix mehr möglich da konnten die typen quasi sich untereinander keine mails mehr schicken und das hat wohl
Richtig stress gemacht weil die wollten sich teilweise noch mal verträge heim schicken per mail oder irgendwelche kollegen zum
geburtstag einladen so was leute ich sag euch riesen paar
riesen panik
und im endeffekt
Ja so was in der richtung und im endeffekt
Ja könnte man jetzt natürlich sagen wir haben gespammt die haben uns zu recht gebannt also
Also ich schon okay
Aber das kannst du jemanden vom außendienst der von der technik halt keine
Ahnung hat nicht erklären und das problem ist halt derjenige der geblockt ist der hat ja auch nicht zwangsläufig gespammt
Also irgendwelche leute haben ein bisschen rum gespammt und dafür sind quasi alle dann alle unsere außendienst mitarbeiter betroffen die halt
Ein email account bei uns haben was halt alle sind und das ist halt doof so und wie das ganze dann
Kurz kurzfassung kurzfassung der ganzen geschichte das ganze ist dann folgendermaßen ausgegangen
Unser
unser experte für mail
Wollte an den support schreiben von gmx
Oder ist sein chef zu ihm gekommen noch das wollte er schreiben an einem tag wo das ganze noch gar nicht so schlimm war
Ja wo es erst noch seit kurzem kaputt war wollte er an den support von gmx schreiben und sagen jungs
Wir scheinen uns geblackliste zu haben und da ist sein chef zu ihm gekommen und hat ihm gesagt nein das machst du jetzt nicht
Dafür haben wir quasi extra service manager stellen die sollen das machen so
Am nächsten tag also sein chef hat es ihm verboten bei gmx nachzufragen
und am nächsten tag
Kommt da rein hat er mir erzählt steht der abteilungsleiter bei ihm am platz
Und meint das muss man sich jetzt mal auf der zuge zergehen lassen und meint ja er ist da in einer
Facebook gruppe wo viele
Außendienstmitarbeiter sind und in dieser facebook gruppe wird gerade darüber diskutiert dass unsere emails nicht gehen
Das heißt da erstmal über facebook erfahren und dann meinte da meinte mein kollege irgendwie ja klar
Ich weiß dass die emails zu gmx und web de nicht gehen wir sind da wahrscheinlich geblacklisted aber ich darf da nix machen
Also ich durfte da nix machen ich das sollte der service manager machen und da ist dann muss das
Und dann und dann als er das erzählen da ging dann halt richtig
Geht es dann halt richtig los zumindest was dann gelaufen ist und jetzt kommt jetzt kommt man wieder der bus des stonks der bus des stonks hammer
Wir haben ja keinerlei
verbindlichen support weder natürlich bei
internet war warum auch wir haben mit denen nichts zu tun noch haben wir verbindlichen support bei unserem spam anbieter wir haben quasi
Mach mal support ticket und innerhalb von 48 stunden reagieren wir also unser spam anbieter war da nicht sonderlich hilfreich
Jetzt passt mal auf
Führungskräfte trick 17 der abteilungsleiter ist dazu seinem chef gegangen und sein chef ist zu unserem it chef gegangen
Und unser it chef dem ist aufgefallen er geht immer ich vermute mal squash tennis oder golf
mit einem von eins und eins spielen
Zumindest zumindest hat er seine kontakte walten lassen oder hat man nach einem halben tag
den kommt den kontakt von einem
Senior boar irgendeinem irgendeinem typ von gmx einem einem senior
Hätte keine hau hette auf spam management ich weiß es nicht ich weiß es nicht was das war
Zumindest zumindest hatten wir dann den kontakt von dem typ weil unser it
IT vorstandstyp irgendwie golf spielen geht mit dem eins und eins
eins vorstandstyp und der kennt irgendeinen typ bei gmx
Na ja zumindest
Hat er den angeschrieben
Und der hat das halt bestätigt dass wir das wir geplacklistet sind
Und dann haben sie uns wieder entplacklisten lassen und dann war wieder alles ok
Ja und zwischenzeitlich haben sie die ganze zeit in die facebook gruppe geguckt ob es da jetzt nicht der shitstorm zusammenbraut und so was also
ganz abgedrehtes zeug
So zumindest was ich mir jetzt überlegt habe beziehungsweise was der kollege bei mir auf der arbeit der sich um unsere mail
Sachen zum höchsten und größten halt kümmert und ich was wir uns heute überlegt haben
Wozu übrigens sein chef auch gesagt hat weiß nicht ob das so eine gute idee ist aber das war alles bevor dieser
Bevor dieser große große stress da war also was wir uns jetzt überlegt haben und das was wir heute auch zum teil im stream bauen
Frage an euch chat was ist die beste möglichkeit zu checken ob man geplacklistet ist
Die euch so einfällt wenn ihr nicht die möglichkeit habt irgendwelche smtp messages oder sonst was auszuwerten oder einfach nur wirklich
blackbox auf nummer sicher gehen wollt
dass ihr
dass eure mails ankommen
Ne nicht auf email protokollebene so ganz ganz brain dead
Ne ne ganz nein ganz ganz brain dead ganz nicht irgendwelche wir reden nicht von dass man weiß was was wie das unter der haube funktioniert
Zumindest auf was auf welche idee wir heute gekommen ist ist folgendes richtig wir machen uns einfach fake accounts
richtig wir machen uns fake accounts
Wir machen uns fake accounts bei
gmx web de strato
eins und eins gmail und sowas
Und dann schicken wir uns mails und wir schicken uns einfach
Haben wir uns überlegt dass wir nicht durch diesen mist noch mal geblockt werden wir schicken uns einfach über eine stunde lang
zehn mails als wir schicken uns quasi oder sagen wir so wir schicken uns alle
Wir schicken uns alle keine ahnung alle zehn minuten alle zehn minuten schicken wir uns eine mail
eine mail an gmx eine mail an eins und eins eine mail an
Gmx an web de so und wenn eine stunde rum ist beziehungsweise wenn zehn mails verschickt wurden
Gehen wir einfach per imap an die ganzen fake accounts dran und gucken ob dort zehn mails in der inbox liegen
Wenn nicht zehn mails in der inbox liegen dann kann man schon mal ein warning raushauen dass man einer nachguckt ob wir nicht wieder
geblacklistet worden sind
Sven supreme dankeschön für den sub
Da habe ich mir so gedacht das müsste ich doch relativ einfach als prometoise exporter programmieren lassen wir brauchen dafür
eigentlich von der idee her ein dotnet programm oder in irgendeinem programm
was smtp sprechen kann was imap sprechen kann
imap sprechen kann
und
was
Prometoise exporter ja eins ist immer so blöd
Eins ist eins ist immer blöd also zehn zehn ist schon besser
Du bekommst näher nicht zwangsläufig also vom smtp vom smtp schon mal nicht du kannst das anhaken dass wenn du die
E-mail liest dass du eine bestätigung kriegst das macht nix leute ganz
So blöd bin ich auch nicht
Ich schreibe einfach einen geheimen string in die email in das email subject
Und nur wenn der geheime string in dem email subject drinne steht nur dann zählt die email als von uns
Super so da muss dann sowas drinne stehen wie super geheimer header string oder so
Wir haben die gespammt wir wissen es nicht genau wir sind uns nur relativ sicher dass es wohl
Zurecht ist der bann was genau weiß ich nicht
Okay, was ich würde nicht auf die anstatt ein bau da eine challenge in die mail die du dann überprüfen kannst zum beispiel
Ja aber
Nee, aber warum ich mache einen geheime string in die email in das email subject dann zähle ich die mails und dann sind zehn
E-mails da und gut ist
Doch, okay, und wenn nur neun da sind ist es schlecht man könnte vielleicht noch
Man könnte vielleicht noch abfangen ob es beim senden ein fehler gegeben hat weil netzwerkprobleme oder so und dann dann zieht man das wo es
Sendefehler gegeben hat ab
Oder ist es nur ein warning oder so müssen wir mal gucken
Ich das weiß ich nicht keine ahnung ich kenne mich mit email ehrlich gesagt auch nicht so gut aus
Na moment zehn mal der gleiche text nicht auf einmal wir schicken zehn mal den gleichen zehn mal die gleiche email an
Fünf und das stimmt nicht wir schicken fünf mal die gleiche email an
An fünf unterschiedliche anbieter also eine email an jedes postfach und das auch nur alle zehn minuten also das ist kein spam
Du kannst die message id setzen ja
Ja aber wozu das man kann es auch unnötig kompliziert machen es müssen einfach zehn emails da sein und wenn und wenn email
Und wenn emails wenn ich zehn emails da sind dann
Ja ist klar das lese ich jetzt schnell nebenbei easy
So und wenn nicht dann passt das
Das bringt mir alles nichts wo soll ich da wissen ob beispielsweise grad
webde entschieden hat unsere mails mal
Zwei stunden irgendwie liegen zu lassen weil zu viel ist oder so
Wo soll das wo sollen die wissen was die intern machen bei bei united internet
Was ich mache wenn die email länger in der queue hängt naja der check geht alle zehn minuten das heißt nach der letzten email
Dauert es zehn minuten bis sie zeit hat da zu da zu sein dann gibt es gibt es halt einen warning dann gibt es halt eine warning
Das dürfen dann die leute die diese am ende verwenden im monitoring einstellen wie sie das haben wollen
Ne das ist nicht problematisch
Da steht nichts dabei was man irgendwie
Zurück da zuordnen könnte
Ja also wie gesagt wenn die email zehn minuten in der queue hängt da gibt es halt einen warning pech gehabt
Und das müsste ganz gut funktionieren also das heißt als erstes leute müssen uns fake emails machen
Wir sind mal komm wir machen uns eine fake email adresse komm wir machen uns eine buggymx, okay
Zum testen zum testen reicht eine fake email adresse würde ich sagen
Was
Alter wie sieht denn die seite aus monka es also registrieren
Nein ich bau das nicht in java wir bauen das in dotnet
Sieben weil java habe ich keinen bock drauf ich lasse doch mal da wieder an also okay wir brauchen was brauche eine gute
Kackel
Kackel fake mail alles klar neutra moment moment moment
Jetzt fühle ich mich aber schon gleich wieder ausgegrenzt hier
So neutral vorname null nachname kackel posterzahl 6 0 3 2 9 frankfurt
Jano die kannst du aber nicht per ein map abfragen
Und du kannst auch per smtp nix hinschicken
Na doch per smtp hinschicken kannst du schon wahrscheinlich was aber du kannst es aber nicht
Per ein map abfragen du kannst den dotnet ohne probleme sachen programmieren jetzt schon das kommt im november raus das funktioniert
Straße kackel street 5
Geburtstag 1.1. 1990
Passwort okay da dürfte jetzt nicht zu kommen
Aber ich habe jetzt schon mal eine fake email adresse und ich habe jetzt schon mal eine fake email adresse
1990 passwort okay da dürfte jetzt nicht zugucken leute
Ich muss auch kurz mal mein password mein password manager
Passwort manager weg machen okay moment passport und ich muss es ja nachher noch schreiben können okay
Okay
Okay sehr gut sehr gutes passwort alles klar password wählen password wählen
Ist es was ist das jetzt sagt er mir dass das password gut ist oder nicht
Ist das password gut oder nicht ich kann es euch zeigen dann wisst ihr ob es gut ist oder nicht
Mobilfunknummer
Muss man das eingeben
Das ist mal lehr zeichen fack
null nein 0151 null
Exzellent
Alles klar das funktioniert schon mal
V6 z1 ey
Wir schützen ihre daten okay email adresse kackel kackel fake mail
Endliche fix punkte alles klar password weiß nur ich sage ich euch nicht
Kann ich nicht entziffern
Alter
Ach muss man das ohne null machen oder wie
Ehm muss die kürzer sein vielleicht
Okay
Fake mail ist ein
E-mail
E-mail ist ein
mobile vorwahl was gibt es denn da alles
aha siehst du deswegen 0 1 5 1 1 1 2 3 1 2
2 dings blub blub ok perfekt dvrd jetzt geht's leute ich sags euch bärm was warum alter
ach so muss man da auch wieder ohne null nee aber das das checkt er schon
weil die mich ver ok die sind so schlau und checken das ok ich guck mal wie lang meine
handynummer ist vielleicht vielleicht ist es vielleicht ist es die was ist das temp
phone number view kann man die seite aufmachen oder wird man da folgespammt mit mit keck
spam shit ok alles klar keine ahnung ich nehme jetzt einfach was von dieser seite da soll
mir recht sein wunderbar bkj mp jetzt aber please alter gmx man ok ich guck mal wie lang
meine handynummer ist weil die können das doch nicht live überprüfen oder das kann
das ist nicht meine telefonnummer leute alles klar excellent ok wie ist die email adresse
die keckel fakemail at gimmicks.de aha aha aha nice zum postfach so da sind wir null
keck ist am start leute null keck sehr schön sehr schön sehr gut das war tatsächlich
schwerer als gedacht ok wir haben es geschafft eine fake email adresse ist am start jetzt
können wir unser projekt anlegen und loslegen hätte ich nicht gedacht dass es so schwierig
ist eine fake handynummer da einzutragen du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du
du ok wunderbar alles klar dann legen wir mal los würde ich sagen äh was nutzt man
bei dotnet heutzutage was was nutzt man bei dotnet eigentlich für die gui heute wp mp
also mauri auf gar keinen fall mach also mauri ist das neue xamarin forms und das war schon
kurze und mauri ist auch müll wpf oder windows forms ja ganz ganz im ernst es ist eigentlich
beides ziemlicher müll ich persönlich würde sagen für ganz kleine quick and dirty sachen
oder wenn man interop mit anderen plattformen haben will ist windows forms noch am besten
weil es einfach windows 32 ist mit ein bisschen mit ein bisschen zucker wpf ist ok windows
only zumindest allerdings ist wpf zwar ein bisschen neuer als windows forms allerdings
auch nicht wirklich moderner von dem was es kann was ich empfehlen würde ist tatsächlich
dass hier was jukjuk schreibt avalonia avalonia ist wirklich nicht schlecht ich habe mit avalonia
selbst noch nichts größeres gemacht das wollte ich demnächst im stream ausprobieren
aber wenn wenn ich gui machen würde heutzutage in dotnet dann avalonia ich brauche keine
wegwerf e-mails ich brauche mails wo ich per imap und smtp draufkomme und uwp kann man
halt auch einfach vergessen wenn es microsoft ja mal irgendwie schaffen würde winui 3 rauszubringen
und dann halt auch so dass man es benutzen kann für normale anwendung dann wäre das
auch eine alternative aber gui frameworks und microsoft das zusammen das funktioniert
einfach nicht das können die nicht ich weiß auch nicht warum aber das können die einfach
nicht so wir haben es geschafft sondern legen wir mal das projekt für heute an wenn er
sich dazu entscheiden kann also mk dir wie heißt das ding mail check champ erstmal dort
net7 updaten alles klar repos mail check champ new console ja dann wollen wir mal so
neues projekt ist angelegt können wir öffnen weiter starten da toolbox kann zu ach fuck
ich habe ja heute mein password geändert für den jetbrains account wahrscheinlich
fliege ich gleich wieder raus leute aus meiner ide da muss ich das password gleich nachgucken
sollte das so weit sein ok open repos mail mail check champ alles klar ok trust wir trusten
alles klar da sind wir so hello world sollte eigentlich machen ja also ok wir können anfangen
übrigens das ist ja auch seit dort net hat mich nicht fünf oder so seit sie ist sie
schaab neun glaube ich so dass man keine main methode mehr braucht dass er das unter der
haufe für ein macht früher musste man hier immer noch machen name space program static
main program bla bla bla jetzt kann man jetzt kann man das alles hier hier direkt reinschreiben
also sprich das hier ist jetzt ein gültiges dort net program was eigentlich ziemlich
ziemlich nice ist so also wir brauchen paar libraries dass das ganze funktioniert das
ganze mit eine konsolen anwendung also brauchen wir wahrscheinlich ein bisschen kommandozeilen
argumenten und sonst was wir brauchen vielleicht farbische farbische kommandozeilen ausgabe
wir brauchen mail kit mail kit ist für smtp und ein map es gibt gefühlt fast jedes jahr
ein neues dort net es gibt jedes jahr neues dort net ja die haben releasezyklus von einem
jahr also es gibt jedes jahr jedes jahr im november erneut dort net version es ist preview
sieben glaube ich aktuell aber das kommt im november raus weiß ich nicht vielleicht
dass es beim verschicken was weiß ich warum die das waren vielleicht dass du nicht spammen
kannst ja cute ist tatsächlich sehr nice problem ist halt c++ und auch die anderen bindings
letztendlich musste irgendwann immer c++ machen ja es gibt jedes jahr neues dort net letztes
jahr 6 davor 5 und jetzt 7 das heißt nächstes jahr 8 das ist finde ich aber auch gut weil
dann tut sich immer was weil es gibt bestimmt welche mögen sich das nicht wenn an den sprachen
und frameworks nicht so viel tut oder wenn man wie bei go 15 jahre auf generics warten
muss aber ich ich ich finde es gut dass sich dort net technisch immer was ändert so was
jetzt habe ich was vergessen also wo sind wir stehen geblieben wir brauchen wir brauchen
mit sicherheit wir brauchen mit sicherheit jason net weil jason braucht man immer jetzt
kommt natürlich der erste und fragt warum ich nicht system text jason serializer verwende
ganz einfach weil ich keinen bock habe und weil das mir bei manchen sachen immer noch
zu kompliziert ist ach ja und in prometheus agent braumer den prometheus exporter library
ok so mit was fangen wir dann an wie wie wie legen wir denn jetzt los ich muss jetzt erstmal
kurz in mich gehen fangen wir mit den email sachen an oder fangen wir mit den fangen
wir mit den mit den prometheus sachen an oder vielleicht müsste ich erst mal ausprobieren
der krempel funktioniert ich glaube ich probiere erstmal aus wie das ganze email zeug funktioniert
also wir brauchen also grob weiß ja wir brauchen den smtp client ops smtp client was will der
haben als option host und port ja gmx imap smtp wie schickt man an gmx was ok mail.gmx.net
alles klar auf port 587 und irgendwie tls oder so ok mail.gmx.net port 587 muss man das überhaupt
so machen oder musste man nicht irgendwas mit connect machen ne send habe ich das richtige
installiert
ich muss kurz mein password eingeben für mein jetbrains account dann haben wir es ihr
dürft gerade nicht zugucken so jetbrains account wo habe ich denn das password für dieses
ding hier das ist auch noch so lang da brauchen wir jetzt wieder 3 stunden das abzutippen und
hoffen dass ich mich nicht vertippe habe ich mich jetzt vertippt nein ich habe mich nicht
vertippt ok nice alles klar activate exit warum warum schmeißt er mich jetzt raus ok ich kann
euch aber wieder anmachen das sollte jetzt funktionieren ne ne ich kann es nicht copy
pasten wenn ich copy paste ist es hier in meiner in meiner history und da soll es nicht drinne
sein ne ich habe zwei monitore sonst könnte ich das ja gar nicht gescheit machen habe
ich wieder eingeschaltet ich habe es falsche eingeschaltet sollte eigentlich längst wieder
was sehen ok passt also github mailkit ich brauche paar examples für mailkit mailkit
documentation examples smtp so smtp client sag doch connect was so was hat er jetzt wieder
für schmerz ne was was moment das ist nicht der smtp client das ist nicht der smtp client
von von mailkit das ist der smtp client von von microsoft shit ich will melkit smtp client
nicht das microsoft ding da ich wusste gar nicht das system netmail den smtp client hat
so smtp client connect so und da wollen wir jetzt mail.gmx.net war es doch oder genau
port 587 war es glaube ich secure socket options ja auto auto wunderbar alles klar ich bin so
was von ok so using und wie geht es jetzt weiter authentic ach mist jetzt muss ich jetzt muss
ich da mal ein password reinschreiben und ihr solltet das password nicht sehen also
muss ich irgendwie mal credentials oder so abrufen über ne ja das kriegen wir hin was
macht man mit prometheuse sehe ich das richtig das ist eine datenbank zum datensammeln gut
also ich würde sagen die meisten datenbanken sind in der regel zum datensammeln prometheuse
ist eine time series database für metrigen klingt jetzt natürlich besonders ab dankeschön
game shock findet ab versteht natürlich kein mensch was wofür das da ist wenn ich das
so sage da kannst du beispielsweise wenn du wenn du eigene anwendung programmierst oder
wenn du server überwachen willst kannst du mit musik lautstärke kannst du werte hinschicken
wie es aktuell ist zum beispiel wie viel ram verbrauch deine anwendung hat wie auf der
garbage collector gelaufen ist oder plattenauslastung von einem system solche sachen also das sind
alles metriken und die schickst du dahin die werden zusammen mit einem timestamp gespeichert
deswegen ist eine time series database und die kannst du dann relativ effizient querien
also da kannst du quasi millionen daten rein machen und hast dann keine 15 minuten bis
die grafen aufbauen wie im zabbix damit du das ganze gut verwenden kannst brauchst du
aber ein ordentliches frontend weil prometheuse selbst sammelt nur ein da brauchst du sowas
wie grafana zum beispiel davor oder ja so zabbix kann diesen prometheuse temple ja auch verarbeiten
ja aber wie gesagt wir machen ja heute kein prometheuse server wir machen den noten wir
machen den prometheuse exporter also sprich ein check wir lesen daten aus und stellen
die auf einer webseite zur verfügung dass prometheuse die abrufen kann prometheuse pullt
nämlich immer nur die ganzen infos also sprich du sagst prometheuse ruft mal von diesen drei
haus die daten ab und dann geht prometheuse in fünf minuten takt oder wie du es eingestellt
hast dahin ruft die daten ab also prometheuse pullt die daten immer kennst du metabase nee
ok und am ende smtp client disconnect ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht das macht er beim
dispose automatisch aber ok so wie kriege ich denn da jetzt mal meine credentials rein
dass ihr die netz sieht leute wir könnten dort net user credentials verwenden da weiß
ich aber ehrlich gesagt gar nicht wie das funktioniert dort net secrets hatte schon mal
jemand verwendet zum dieses dort net tool zum secret speichern also dass das eingebaute
dort net user secrets set doch doch doch du kannst du kannst environment variablen machen
das geht aber das will ich eigentlich gar nicht mal wisst ihr was ich habe kein bock
jetzt irgendwelche super super komplizierten sachen zu machen wir machen das einfach so
glas secrets static string mx schreibt es einfach hier rein und gut das lull so mal gucken
ob ihr das jetzt seht wie gesagt kann man schöner machen aber für jetzt gmx passwort
ok mal es wird nicht angezeigt was es ist wunderbar dann schreibe ich jetzt einfach kurz das
passwort rein einfach vererben von was vererben von wo also verstehe ich das richtig dass
die auswertungs protokolle per email schicken lassen nee wo habe ich denn sowas gesagt
gar nicht ich will email schicken und gucken ob die emails ankommen ich schicke mir selbst
emails ich meine der test von gmx zu gmx ist ziemlich blöd also ich bräuchte um genau
zu sein eigentlich noch einen zweiten account von dem ich schicken kann an gmx aber letztendlich
ist es für die logik darunter egal und ich kann es von einem account besser testen also
das ziel ist mir selbst emails zu schicken und zu gucken ob alle ankommen wie gesagt
normalerweise würde ich natürlich auch nicht von einem gmx account an den gleichen account
schicken sondern von bei uns auf der arbeit über unseren spam anbieter an gmx an gmail
an webde und dann gucken ob nach einer stunde zehn emails angekommen sind aber so zum test
muss das reichen so leute ihr müsst jetzt noch mal kurz ihr dürft jetzt mal kurz nicht
gucken weil ich jetzt das password hier reinschreiben muss das password ist übrigens wenn
ich liel wenn ich es liegen sollte finde das bestimmt der chain law besonders lustig aber
ich liege es ja nicht so ich hoffe ihr habt genau ich hoffe ihr habt euch alle die augen
zugehalten und ich darf jetzt die secrets zartei heute nicht mehr öffnen lull ich meine
selbst wenn ich es liege ist nicht ist nicht wild dann lösche ich halt einfach ich lösche
heute die email adresse wieder am ende am ende des streams ok also smtp client connect
mail.gmx.net smtp client jetzt wahrscheinlich send und wie sendet meine email adresse wie
sendet meine email darüber das ist natürlich jetzt spannend wie macht man habe ich keine
ahnung wie das funktioniert smtp examples send message message send message ja ja jetzt
wird nirgendswo aufgerufen ok keine ahnung wie man das macht also send message too sharp
das ist eine gute idee das ist eine wirklich gute idee ja da hast du recht das ist eine
gute idee ja ja massive fivehead nur mein chat ist so fiveheadig auf so ideen zu kommen
so also das heißt im endeffekt wir brauchen erstmal eine message die wir senden können
also war message gleich knew my message und was muss man dann da reinschreiben chat hat
extrem hohen eq aber das ist ja mittlerweile auch schon bekannt das wissen wir ja der chat
ist richtig massive brain so empfänger to gleich new mailbox address nee das ging mit
pass irgendwie das kenne ich schon mailbox address pass moment gmx wie heißt unser
excellent die leute sind schon wieder ab spam hier so guckt euch an alter tja was willst
du machen so ist halt so ist es halt ich werde jetzt einfach diesen account nie wieder öffnen
sondern ein map abfragen so also to mailbox address pass was wollen wir sonst noch haben
subject aber das ist gut dass ihr spamt weil da kann ich testen ob mein magic string funktioniert
wobei wenn ihr den magic string seht dann funktioniert es ja nicht weil dann weiß ich
dass die leute auch schon anfangen mit so komischen dingern deswegen jebaiter ich euch
einfach und mein magic string mit random und ihr wisst ihn gar nicht easy war random gleich
new nee wir machen es ein war gut ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das dann mit nullen initialisiert
ist oder nicht ich kann mir das immer nicht merken dass jetzt ist es jetzt mit nullen initialisiert
wenn ich so mache oder muss ich new machen das kann ich mir nie merken ist alles gut
also subject subject ist kackel mail und dann immer immer ordentlich und dann all die so
und die wisst ihr nicht deswegen könnt ihr auch nicht spam damit outplayed chat
also send subject haben wir ja feifert subject haben wir tu was brauchen wir denn sonst noch
from oder muss man oder war das sender
email email krempel ich habe keine ahnung was der unterschied zwischen from und sender
ist aber wir schreiben einfach mal das gleiche rein wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich
geht es so auch oder so und jetzt müssen dann muss da eben den text rein body gleich
text text part test ok beste beste email überhaupt ok also ich muss from verwenden ok so jetzt
haben wir unsere mail und die senden wir jetzt message alles klar ich muss mich noch authentifizieren
smtp client authenticate string username kackel fakemail gmx.de und password secrets password
ok dann schauen wir mal ob das senden jetzt funktioniert ran also wenn es ohne fehlermeldung
durchläuft sollte das senden funktioniert haben und ich habe die ich habe die ad ausgegeben
natürlich sehr sehr schlau gewesen leute so credentials invalid
auch sitz hier invalid alter nerv nicht gmx was fehlgeschrei langer zugriff hallo lull
kackel sie haben kürzlich versucht ihr gmx postfach in ein email programm wie zum beispiel
autokolle die vorenstehende meld moment was es ist mtp und ein map ist deaktiviert sehe
ich das richtig aha die für diese postvereinstellung ok was kbbcdk excellent
ok sehr schön also sehr nice jetzt gucken wir mal ob es noch mal funkt ob es jetzt funktioniert
jetzt hat es funktioniert und ist die email angekommen kackel fakemail net gmx nice attachment
ist nicht bewusst dass ich dann attachment dran gehauen habe aber ok da lasse ich das
mit dem lasse ich das mit dem test einfach weg das sollte auch so funktionieren moin
drachenflieger ok email adresse kommt an alles klar warum muss jetzt so ich muss nicht rein
rein freiwillige sache weil ich mir gedacht habe das eignet sich wunderbar für den stream
ok also jetzt weiß ich schon mal wie man emails versendet und jetzt muss ich noch gucken wie
man emails abruft ok wahrscheinlich ein map kleint wie kriegt man das hier dann raus
ein map example ein map kleint ein map kleint gleich new ein map kleint vermute ich mal
ja sehr schön ein map kleint connect ja ok das kann ich mir copy pasten ich kann mir
beides copy pasten eigentlich ein map kleint so und das ist ein map punkt gmx allerdings
in den anderen port 993 ok ist klar gmx so wie ruft man jetzt ein map was ab ein map kleint
in box in box klingt schon mal gut daco xdv lang ist schon verhindert ab so in box klingt
schon mal gut recent alter wie viel watte wie viel hatten das
monkeys das hat 100 metoden alter ist ja mal gut hier was to immutable array kommt da am
ende raus ach da kriegt man die einzelnen messages hier das ist ja auch nicht schlecht
was bedeutet mail monitor ich will überprüfen und melde sich sende ankommen ok wie muss
ich wie sagen ok also klein in box open search und dann eine schleife drüber also das vermute
ich mal muss ich auf jeden fall machen weil sonst nicht funktionieren wird in box open
folder access read only ja meinetwegen ok subject machen wir mal mein bahn hier weg
gucken wir mal ob das ein map zeug funktioniert also ein map oder kann ich hier gleich select
machen ach so das brauche ich gar nicht lull einfach so machen ja mails ok for each mail
in mails was innumerables subject quatsch ich will die message komplett haben subject
ja doch ist ok er gibt zwar von der benahmung her keinen sinn aber ich will mal überprüfen
so jetzt sollte ich die ganzen dummen emails von euch auch bekommen wenn alles funktioniert
tatsächlich hier guck mal die leute haben ich ihr habt mich zwar zu sonst was angemeldet
aber es funktioniert kackel mail und uid ist hinten dran wieso machst du die leerzeichen
vor die klammer wo habe ich leerzeichen vor der klammer
das im github archiv was 38 und 34 ach da ja ne das soll nicht das soll tatsächlich
nicht sein das da weiß ich nicht warum die das machen kann ich nicht sagen das ist nicht
von mir das ist die die die hilfe seite für die library warum die das machen keine ahnung
es scheint das scheint system zu haben bei denen vielleicht gefällt ihm das kann jeder
machen wie er will also ich finde es jetzt auch nicht gerade toll so also das funktioniert
schon einmal wir können emails abrufen ich bin begeistert elite partner sehr gut weiß
ja bescheid chat wie ist das alle zehn minuten verliebt sich ein single wenn man das mal
ausrechnet wie viele leute bei elite partner wahrscheinlich sind es alle zehn minuten
ganz schön wenig da wartest du wahrscheinlich rein rechnerisch 800 jahre drauf bis ihr das
was bringt also zumindest das funktioniert schon mal und jetzt kann man natürlich noch
filtern subject wir machen das einfach anders wehr message subject starts with was haben
wir hier kackel mail select ja wobei brauche ich eigentlich gar nicht alles gut mails mail
subject tweet von golang schon gesehen ne haben die denn getweetet programming language
ja und weiter wurde wurde der account gehackt oder was möchten sie uns sagen
max spielst du schon da auf ihnen ne es ist ja kann auch alpha test und alles fliegt weg
ich hatte kein bock die also ich habe mir den char erstellt zwei charts als die aufgemacht
haben alpha test aber ich weiß wie sieht die pop wie sieht denn aktuell überhaupt noch
die spielerzahlen aus bringt das was da was los guck mal was der kanzler getweetet hat
ok ne ja was hat er getweetet ok chat er hat getweetet gar nix hat er getweetet der 25 august
zuletzt was getweetet wieviel spielen denn abends immer so amorphium wieviel sind immer
so aktiv also eigentlich also dass da gut ist müssen es eigentlich um die mindestens
tausend sein was aber auch frisch als halt immer so ein ding ist so also wo sind wir
stehen geblieben das funktioniert wunderbar was jetzt oh internal server error what the
fuck intern haben haben die meine email gesperrt alter leute zu was meldet ihr mich da alles
an monka es
darum internal server error ach jetzt gehts wieder ich glaube ich habe einfach zu oft
ich glaube ich habe das ganze zu oft ausgeführt so am ende bin ich wahrscheinlich mit dieser
email adresse wirklich angemeldet den den afd infobrief haben wir schon die beate den
beate use newsletter alles alles alles dabei hier frankfurter zeitung newsletter wer liest
noch zeitung zu porno wurde wahrscheinlich mit der email adresse auch schon angemeldet
aber macht euch nix draus ich werde die email adresse eh löschen am ende des streams also
machen wir mal weiter so also ich weiß jetzt wie ich emails sende und ich weiß jetzt wie
ich emails empfange dann checken wir doch mal ob ich eine email senden kann und dann
warte ich mal 15 sekunden und dann müsste ich die email ja eigentlich finden so das
probieren wir mal aus soweit soweit von der theorie wenn das funktioniert können wir
mit der eigentlichen sache weitermachen wait task was das task delay keine ahnung 15 sekunden
geben wir immer zeit dass die email ankommt und danach löschen wir alle mails leute ich
werde es gleich alle mails löschen von euch immer automatisch nach dem ausführen 15 sekunden
warten jetzt wenn ich richtig gezählt habe oder wahrscheinlich habe ich nicht richtig
gezählt ja hat funktioniert guckt kackel mail mit der uid also email senden email checken
funktioniert das heißt was wir jetzt machen werden ist folgendes zum schluss wir werden
sagen alle mails also for each war mail in imap client inbox wie löscht man mails mail
kit delete mail weiß nicht wie das funktioniert make it delete single mail message single
mails jawohl erzählt mir wie es geht klein in box et flex message deleted ok also hoffentlich
passt das hier imap in box et flex gibt es auch nur et flac et flex aber wie funktioniert
das jetzt mail id uid wie kriege ich denn die id von der mail gar nicht oder oder
ist message id ist die ne ne das was anderes wie krieg ich denn die id ach hier search query
all ok das jetzt schon massiv umständlich aber ok ich copy paste mir einfach mal den
graben von ihm hier imap client search warum macht er da immer so ein lehrzeichen ich verstehe
es denn weil wir können das wir können das einfacher machen hier so ok imap ist halt
mal wieder umständlich hoch 10 uid uid und jetzt message flex deleted silent ja meinetwegen
alles silent wunderbar und jetzt was muss man machen zum mail löschen in box was expungi
expunge hat jemand dieses wort schon mal gehört ich das also was heißt das überhaupt löschen
was expunge wie spricht man das überhaupt aus achso ux ux pung delete is to three hat
das kann ich jeder ja das geht nicht so einfach imap client in box ex alter was kram gut dafür
muss ich das ding allerdings nicht read öffnen sondern read write öffnen gehe ich mal von
aus also ein bisschen status meldung reinschreiben send mail waiting delete all mails so auf gehts
mail senden gucken ob es da ist und dann alles löschen danach ist nicht das ungewöhnliche
wort habe ich schon nie gehört das hört sich an wie eine attacke aus einem anime ja tatsächlich
hat was aber da muss noch ein bisschen was dazu ein paar deutsche worter noch dabei die
mögen aus irgendwelchen gründen deutsche namen allein sei möglichst lang ok die liet
all mails gucken wir mal ob er alle mails deleted hat dass ich mir nicht mal angucken
muss was er mir sonst noch hier alles schickt alles weg hat funktioniert und ihm gelöscht
im spam verdacht ist ganz viel was ok ich weiß nicht zu was er mich da angemeldet hat
aber es egal c++ meeting sehr schön aber jeder twitch dein twitch bestätigungscode
ah das ist gut das ist gut dass man das in der email sieht das heißt es kann sich jetzt
irgendjemanden twitch account erstellen mit der email adresse weil weil und so macht es
mir egal die email adresse ist eh weg nach der nach dem stream
ja so könnte das tatsächlich heißen ultrahass expansions wobei wobei die aussprache moment
wir müssen was testen leute wie ist die wie ist die anime aussprache von diesem wort
dass das testen wir jetzt mal ich habe hier mein text text to speech der dann so sachen
aussprechen kann wie zum beispiel ok schauen wir mal ich habe vergessen was ich machen
muss dass man text to speech nicht nicht krascht das seht sie so wie hoffentlich krascht es
nicht nicht kraschen please also guck mal wie sprich wie würde das anime technisch
ausgesprochen werden ziemlich ziemlich genauso stelle ich mir vor wird es da ausgesprochen
das klingt also das klingt ziemlich ok ok ich übernehme mal was von euch genau so würde
das klingt also das ist tatsächlich sehr original ja genau so stelle ich mir das tatsächlich
vor würde sich das anhören du verstehst da ja nix sehr schön gut also so viel so viel
flash bang also das tut das tut schon mal wir können schon mal emails abfragen emails
löschen und emails checken ob die id drinne ist das ist schon mal nice nachdem die basics
funktionieren können wir das ganze jetzt ja auch ein bisschen schöner machen
also das funktioniert alles wieder alle mails gelöscht wenn du geh mal auf github trend
was github trend soll discontinued werden was anscheinend nicht nichts discontinued
hätte mich auch sehr gewundert warum sollte github trend discontinued werden was da gucke
ich total oft rein alter warum streichen die immer irgendwelche sinnvollen features
warum streichen die immer sinnvolle features ganz ehrlich ich persönlich benutze echt gerne
das trending tab weil ich habe ich habe über das trend ich mache das mal in einem anonymen
tab auch vielleicht gibt vielleicht muss ich eingeloggt sein vielleicht muss ich vielleicht
muss ich eingeloggt sein aber ich habe schon total viel zeug gefunden über über das
trending vor allem weil du hier auf language stellen kannst das findet ihr mal besonders
spannend na du stellst auf language und kannst gucken was denn was denn für deine ja bevor
zu was denn so aktuelles trend ich finde dass ich finde das wirklich eine super sache mit
dem trending tab warum löscht man so was was ist denn das für ein schwachsinn schon
wieder ich guck mal jetzt haben wir zum beispiel was gelernt dass es einen standard gibt ich
weiß nicht mal was das sein soll hier oft hier fast health care interoperability resources
er ja ok alles klar ja warum maui trendet kann ich nicht verstehen also mit den krebs
verwendet dem ist echt nicht mehr zu helfen guck china chinesen zeug trendet benchmark
dotnet super library ja kommunikations ok gehts da gehts da um trending tab i got the
message ja also jeden tag ist vielleicht jeden tag ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben
aber ich gucke da mehrfach die woche rein was trendet oh nein jetzt sind die kpop spammer
auch hier schon am start ja die haben recht also es also wenn man das trending tab abschafft
wäre wirklich richtig dumm maui nicht die erhoffte erlösung für dotnet xamarin war
nicht die erhoffte lösung und maui hat glaube ich nicht niemand als erlösung als ui framework
erhofft ja ich habe dankeschön für den rate field ich habe auch schon einige sachen darüber
gefunden die ich sehr spannend finde also es ist total hängen geblieben wenn die sagen
würden wir discontinuen github trends das wäre einfach nur mega bescheuert also ich
gucke immer hier explore trending und alles mögliche von daily bis sonst wie ich gucke
die sprachen durch ich finde es interessant zu sehen was allgemein trendet weil ich habe
keine ahnung was das ist habe ich ja nie gehört ja gerade sowas nach sowas suchst du doch normalerweise
nicht das das findest du jetzt hier in sponsors guckst dir an und denkst dir ach so eigentlich
ganz cool ich verstehe das nicht das ist ein bisschen wie mit dem dislike button also mittlerweile
werden die funktionen teilweise also für mich essenzielle core funktionalität eingeschränkt
aus aus ja weiß ich besseren monetarisierungsgründen was anderes ist es ja übrigens bei github
wahrscheinlich auch nicht bessere monetarisierungsgründe unterm strich das hat die welt gebraucht wir
brauchen nicht wpf 2 wir brauchen ein ordentliches avalonia wenn schon ich meine ich bin kein
samuel fan muss ich sagen samuel samuel wie immer das ausspricht aber alles ist besser als
samuel und maui so ich habe gesagt wir können das ganz jetzt noch ein bisschen ordentlich machen also
lasst mal überlegen wie würde man das dann machen also die basis funktionalität wissen wir
dass sie funktioniert email schicken emails emails empfangen also wir machen mal sowas hier public
static class das irgendwie sowas wie keine mon mail sender da gibt es nur eine methode drin public
static cool tricent so da brauchen wir string ne provokant zwing da brauchen wir mail box
address zu der die email adresse sind ja immer gleich die ups die die messages sind ja immer
gleich also tricent so da machen wir dann tricatch block drumherum und return falls wenn der kram
kann man das diskern wenn der kram aus irgendwelchen gründen nicht klappt mit dem senden und wir
return true und senden die mail wenn alles funktioniert solltest du den klein nicht noch
disconnecten mache ich das nicht ja du hast recht also ich vermute aber mal dass ich das nicht
machen muss weil wir gucken mal nach ob ich das machen muss oder ob das überflüssig ist weil
der wahrscheinlich disposable implementiert hätte ich hätte ich gedacht ja das post
dispose alter wo ist es denn jetzt bescheuert muss doch irgendwo sein
wo ist es aber irgendwie kann man irgendwie suchen nach groß und kleinschreiber
ist es doch
versuchst du eigentlich nach so was wie solle zu programmieren ja die sachen davon die sinnvoll
sind schon in dem kontext warum nicht ja zum beispiel dass eine sache als eine klasse nichts
von der anderen wissen soll dass eine klasse nur eine sache machen soll das hat schon durchaus
aus seinen sinn ich kann dir aber gerne ich kann dir aber aus dem kopf nicht sagen was die einzelnen
punkte von soll es sind also single single responsibility open close oder sowas ich habe
keine ahnung was die letzten drei was sie noch heißen ja ja ja da also da wo es sinnvoll ist
schon dass das hat das hat ja seinen sinn muss man sagen also der macht kein disconnect
guck mal der macht kein disconnect also ich muss tatsächlich von hand disconnecten ich
hätte gedacht der disconnected sich das natürlich bescheuert disconnect unten drunter
disconnect nach ex ex punch muss ich disconnecten die try send mail 2 dann können wir uns diesen
camp von hier oben schnappen dass wir das ein bisschen aufräumen bevor das nächste mal also
wir kriegen heute das garantiert nicht alles hin aber die basis sachen haben wir schon mal
ausprobiert dass das nächste mal halbwegs ordentlich ist weil so blick ich da blick
ich da nicht mehr durch ja mal aus kommentieren also im endeffekt machen wir dann so was wie
mail sender send try send an mailbox address pass sowas hier das ist natürlich ein bisschen
schöner als dieser ganze rotz auf einmal hast du eine ahnung wie lange du streben wirst ja eine
stunde noch ungefähr juck das schreibt ich muss mich mal bedanken ich habe dich ja gefragt mit
welcher sprache ich anfangen soll hab dann angefangen jetzt bin ich richtig trinne heckermans ja so
muss das sein dazu kann ich sagen macht mir mittlerweile mehr spaß als hartware zu ich bin
gerade schon ob ich mir mit mit einer c spa oder so und da go weiter machen soll dank auf jeden was
habe ich dir denn geraten mit was zu anfangen sonst habe ich gesagt mach javascript also das
ist ja so meine standardsache wenn man nicht weiß was man machen will mach javascript habe
ich dir auch gesagt mach javascript ja genau das ist gut ja also wenn du eine c styles sprache
lernst dann mach auf jeden fall sie scharp und fang auf gar keinen fall mit c++ an und c
selbst ist halt ja gut wenn du hardware zeugs machen willst ist c sicherlich nicht verkehrt
gerade für arduino in esp ist das halt immer noch das mittel der wahl aber wenn du ordentliche
anwendung entwickeln willst auch für desktop und so was dann auf jeden fall dort netz die
scharp damit wird gar nicht mehr c++ anfangen und go ja gut das kannst du das kannst du
dir im endeffekt aussuchen ich persönlich würde mir als nächstes tatsächlich wenn
du was anderes machen willst dort net angucken beziehungsweise ist die scharp weil ich finde
von der sprache her vom umfang her und von den einsatzmöglichkeiten her mit der beste
kombination die es gibt allerdings go ist auch nicht verkehrt go ist auch eine gute
sprache zum einsteigen beziehungsweise zum weitermachen gibt es noch ein hetzer stream
ich habe noch nicht gesprochen mit hetzer beziehungsweise ich weiß gar nicht ob mein
managers was geschrieben hat oder ob es da schon was neues gibt keine ahnung wahrscheinlich
hoffe ich mal weil wir müssen es ja noch mal ordentlich bauen von dem was wir das letzte
mal gemacht haben ich wohne an der grenze zur schweiz denkst du dass ich lieber eine
fachinformatik ausbilden deutschland drei jahre oder in der schweiz vier also ganz
ehrlich wenn du nähe von der schweiz wohnst dann gehen die schweiz und kriegt mehr geld
das ist ja dann das ja premium schweizer gehalt und und deutsche kosten ja ich werde im zuge
vom informatik im abi java lernen unabhängig davon dass ich es mir auch sonst vorgenommen
habe nachdem ich arduino in der elfen gehabt habe ja ich persönlich bin ja kein großer
java fan aber ganz im ernst es ist auch absolut in ordnung kann man machen immer muss nicht
alles mögen aber ich ich ich mag ja war nicht sonderlich so super super geheime string
schreiben wir jetzt als rein hier super geheim das kennen nur ich danach kann ich greppen
später da weiß ich dass ich die mail selbst geschickt habe ja das wundert mich auch dass
man arduino in der schule lernt das kommt aber wahrscheinlich ganz entscheidend auf
den lehrer an wenn du da irgendwelche planlose leute hast wie ich die quasi alles feiern
nur weil die eindrückung stimmt nicht doch stimmt die alles feiern nur weil du in wird
die schrift an lila machst so ein hat ich in weiß gar nicht wie man das genannt hat
bei uns in der schule ich glaube it hieß das damals von leuten die keine ahnung haben
wahnsinn also das war wirklich komplett komplett unsinnig ja du musstest du musstest bei
diesem typ einfach nur dein powerpoint und wird text lila machen dann hat er gesagt leila
leila leila leila mag ich oder hast du eine eins gekriegt der war ein bisschen über der
spur der kerl und ich mein it bestand in der schule bei mir aus powerpoint und wird was
was ist da los was ist da los chain law warum geht das nicht das ist das ist schlecht wenn
es nicht geht weil ich gucke beispielsweise auch gerne zum pennen streams und wenn dann
auf einmal werbung kommt das ist dann richtig oder oder man könnte eigentlich fast schon
sagen es ist wo habe ich eigentlich mein monka es easy Leute ich kann mich nicht mehr konzentrieren
ich weiß wir haben nicht viel gemacht aber sie schon spät ich kann mich nicht mehr konzentrieren
ich muss das andere mal weitermachen wir haben nur wir haben eigentlich nur gecheckt wie
man e-mails abruf
das war was wir morgen irgendwann weiter gucken ich kann mich nicht konzentrieren weil es
zu spät ich habe den ganzen tag schon zeug gebastelt für twitch gibt es einen blokker
ne ich muss noch nicht ich muss auch nicht gleich oft aber wir können ein bisschen können
ein bisschen schwätzen noch ne ne es gibt es gibt uplog origin uplog origin macht für
die meisten seiten mein twitch ist so on of twitch geht mal mal geht es nicht
ok wie löst man den account wieder hat irgendjemand eine ahnung wie man sein gmx konto löscht
e-mails schreiben gmx delete my account deleting an account
my account ok
wo home home
mein account account löschen account löschen ihr password
ok leute ich copy ich copy paste jetzt das password und löscht dann jetzt löschen
ok kann ich euch auch zeigen wie das password war moment
ich zeige euch das nicht da kann ich das nächste mal wieder verwenden ich habe tabs offen ja
ich weiß ich habe gerne ich habe gerne viele tabs offen
excellent leute wir machen ein andermal weiter ne das password das password enthielt das
password und dann kam noch was blödes hinten dran weil er hat zufälligerweise grad was
im chat geschrieben wo ich das password eingegeben habe und das password ist gewesen ist ein
aber jetzt sage ich nicht was ich weiter geschrieben habe aber nix schlimmes nix ja sowas in der
richtung steht da ja sowas in der richtung ich kann so ich ok ich copy pastes euch hier
das das das war das password chain law ist ein three head spammer das ist mir grad so
eingefallen als ich die e-mail adresse angelegt habe weil er was im chat geschrieben hat
das ist ein gutes password leute das ist ein wirklich gutes password das ist lang 123456
wobei warum zähle ich das eigentlich selbst lul lul Sachen selber zählen ich glaube es
geht los keine sonderzeichen keine zahlen das ist bei der länge doch auch vollkommen
egal ja echo bam wc 28 zeichen leute da kannst du nur klein buchstaben oder kannst du sogar
nur zahlen machen das reicht 28 28 stellen 28 stellen kannst du im prinzip dein password
nur so zusammensetzen kriegt schon keiner raus kannst du vergessen 28 stellen ist heilig
die secure was hier die weeps sind am start ich seh schon chat gibts noch irgendwas spannendes
murkser ah ist sicher konfirm du ich ganz im ernst ich glaube bei den meisten seiten würde
es relativ lange dauern bis einer damit in den account reinkommt ja du kannst bei den
meisten sachen nicht allzu viele requests pro sekunde machen bevor die dich blocken
und selbst wenn du eine datenbank verwendest mit bekannten password dann wird das wahrscheinlich
drin stehen wird brauchst du trotzdem eine weile also ja wahrscheinlich bist du damit
sicherer als die meisten leute die wir wissen noch wir wissen noch als 123456 das verbreiteste
password ist und wahrscheinlich gefolgt von querz also bei passwörtern ist best practice
einfach das zu nehmen was alle nehmen meistens nicht so gut ja genau das werden die wenigst
noch machen 123 wird kaum noch akzeptiert das ist richtig die meisten wollen dass man
macht 123456 und noch score a oder sowas weil du brauchst sonderzeichnung groß und kleinschreibung
manchmal muss doch so machen aber ganz ehrlich seitdem ich den password manager verwende
also jahrelang ja schon immer der gleiche habe ich das problem nicht mehr da lasse ich
mir dort ein password generieren es kommt höchstens manchmal vor dass mein password
manager ein password generiert und die seite dann sagt oh nee das password ist zu lang
oder irgendwie was oder das password enthält kein sonderzeichen wobei das ja absicht ist
dafür sind die langen aber das ist auch nicht schlecht das sieht aus wie ein beispiel beispiel
installation wo man aus dem tutorial das password raus kopiert hat ich benutze key pass seit
ewigkeiten das da ja last pass wurde gehackerment allerdings haben sie gesagt es hatte keinen
einfluss auf die passwörter das finde ich gut das kommt rein keck keck alu add to channel
bem ist drinnen leute ich habe es hinzugefügt ich aktualisieren mal kurz keck alu wie geht
nicht ach nee man schreibt es alles groß man schreibt also keck alu ne hat noch nicht
aktualisiert leute aber ich habe es hin ich habe es hinzugefügt keck alu geht noch nicht
jetzt bei euch bei mir jetzt nicht ich habe es hinzugefügt bald bald gibt es keck alu
eine minuten cdn update aber ich finde keck alu so nice das nehme ich das nehme ich mit
auf nicht hat was ich bin der einzige der das hinzugefügt hat dieses bild ist es von
dir ich finde das mega keck alu anscheinend funktioniert es doch nicht ja mobile hast du
keine ffz emotes das ist normal wir haben wirklich bei wir haben alle alle keck emotes
durch ja ich mein guckt mal keck also wir haben also eine wir haben eine wirklich sehr
breite auswahl an keck emotes und und lull lull emotes haben wir gar nicht so viel aber
monka haben wir monka haben wir auch einige monka steer ist sehr underused aber gut wozu
auch ja meistens passt ja nicht zum kontext keck weep im anime style ne wir haben genug
weep emotes
um nicht zu vergessen für alle für die weeps out fraktion guck mal allein schon vier davon
kann man sich nicht alle emotes anzeigen lassen warum nicht ist nicht aktiviert oder was
oder muss man dafür eingeloggt sein weil die autover vollständigung geht ja das
ist
gibt ich werde übrigens nicht ich werde mir rings of power nicht geben habe ich mir vorgenommen
weil näher ich wollte ich habe mir erst überlegt man könnte der ganzen sache ja mal eine chance
geben aber mir hat das alles das ganze hin und her darum wirklich nicht grad bock auf die sendung
gemacht keine ahnung ich juckt mich juckt mich nicht ich ich glaube auch nicht dass amazon das
sinnvoll hinbekommt also ich bin bei sowas eh schon immer sehr sehr kritisch ja und habe
was rum zu meckern ich glaube es werde ich mir nicht gucken ich sage einfach nur ich bin ich
angucken werde weil ich nicht glaube dass das die zeit wert ist was eigentlich auf dieser
blackout serie gewonnen keine ahnung ich weiß es nicht nein tatsächlich war ich noch nicht weil
ich korona hatte ich könnte mich da aber eigentlich mal wieder melden weil das ist jetzt ja schon
eine weile vorbei war kurz in die e-mails gucken was haben wir denn da neu ist drinne
youtube sponsorship ok hört mal genau zu leute jetzt jetzt kommen die massive youtube sponsorship
sachen youtube sponsorship mit world class vpn client this is paras vom creator db so und ich
soll ich soll werbung machen für wie die sagen mir noch nicht mal für welchen vpn anbieter ich
werbung machen soll die sagen ich soll werbung machen für one of the best vpn companies in
the industry 60 60 bis 90 sekündige video integration ja aber der sagt nicht mal für welchen
ok was haben wir sonst noch schönes attention youtubers sponsorship opportunity da ist so
viel crap dabei immer please contact us please contact us hong kong whatsapp alles klar hong
kong whatsapp da habe ich ja direkt bock drauf mit ihnen was zu machen die haben echt probleme
oder sowas in der richtung kooperationsanfrage das ist gut übersetzt leute das ist gut übersetzt
hallo wir haben mit vielen twitch ankern zusammengearbeitet gradios übersetzt das
ist ja geil also das muss ich euch vorlesen also das ok moment moment chat mal refreshen
gucken wir mal ob keck alu funktioniert kann jetzt noch mal ausprobieren geht keck alu jetzt
keck alu nein geht immer nicht also hört euch hört euch das mal an also jentung zung
zung stehts in der stehts in der email und da steht hallo ich bin jenny von dumm dumm
dumm advertising wir haben mit vielen twitch ankern zusammengearbeitet derzeit haben wir
ein deutsches latex kissen das beworben werden muss sie können dieses produkt den fans zeigen
und sie während der live übertragung anleiten besorgen wenn sie an diesem kooperationsmodell
und produkt interessiert sind können sie unter meine kontaktdaten hinzufügen produkt link
deutschlands kopfkissen nummer eins in vollkommenheit das ist ja war so schlecht ein latex kissen
was
ich bin mir da auch nicht so sicher nein nein das da das da die meint die mein tatsächlich
nicht nicht ich frage wenn müsste sie eigentlich man müsste eigentlich ganz doof zurückfragen
was sie davon meint und dann warten wie verwirrend die antwort ist weil ich mein wenn die wenn
die ursprüngliche anfrage schon wir ist dann ist die antwort noch wirer wurde der art eigentlich
auch von krabb geprägt nö warum sollte warum sollte es also ich habe gar keinen prog krabb
ich habe buch buch d oder irgendwie sowas ich habe kein grub gibt kein grub bei mir warum
warum was was was war da krabb probt mein art stillungsinstallation ok warum
ok was ist passiert
nee mach ich nicht ach nee fuck
ist das gefixt mittlerweile
ok gucken wir mal hat er hat er das verlinkt hier unten irgendwie archback report krabb
closed haben sie gefixt
ach guck mal manjaro ist mal wieder betroffen alles klar
Ok, Banjaro Crabb, Zeus, ja ist das, ist das denn jetzt prinzipiell gefixt?
Da muss ich mal kurz danach gucken.
Ok anscheinend interessiert das kein Banjaro, wo werden Banjaro Bugs reportet?
Haben die sowas überhaupt?
Ne?
Ja, ich habe kein Bock mein Notebook irgendwie kaputt zu machen auf der Arbeit mit einem
Update. Okay also das soll man machen danach noch mal okay. Interessant. Einfach nicht
Upgraden, Pfeifert. Was? Okay ich weiß nicht mal wovon er spricht, aber okay.
Ja das wissen wir jetzt.
Also ich hoffe die fixen das so, dass man keine Zusatzbefehle mehr ausfüllen muss,
weil wenn ich mal mein Notebook update denke ich doch nicht dran den Kram da irgendwie noch zu
updaten oder das noch zu machen.
Ja, kein Schimmer. Was das Problem war das habe ich nicht so genau gecheckt wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Irgendwas das Manjaro irgendeinen Crab install macht nach dem Crab update und das macht irgendwie
kaputt. Man kann auch einfach den kernel per evi shell starten, das kriege ich aber aus dem
Kopf nicht hin wenn mein Notebook morgens kaputt ist. Müsste ich dann erst mal im Handy gucken wie
man das macht. Und ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob ich überhaupt einen Crab auf der Arbeit drauf
habe. Aber ich glaube schon das ist ja die default bootloader. Also würde ich jetzt einfach mal von
ausgehen. Ne, will ich nicht. So ist das gut. Das haben wir doch schon mal schon geguckt vor ewig
kann. Ja Leute, wenn sonst nichts mehr gibt soll ich mal refreshen. Geht das jetzt mittlerweile?
Wenn sonst nichts mehr ist wie gesagt ich kann mich nicht weiter konzentrieren. Ach hier guck mal
image funktioniert. Pog hat eine weile gedauert bis es refreshed ist. Alles klar dann sehen wir
uns morgen chat. Morgen geht's weiter. Bis denn macht's gut. CU.